I feel like Ralph all of a sudden whoa
this is really weird man I don't know if
I was told to go and he'd follow he's in
costume and I haven't seen it and he
wanted to surprise me
[Music]
[ __ ] dick unbelievable it is Saturday
night in Hollywood so let's battle the
[ __ ] on let's see how we handle this I'm
Kevin Smith
I'm Kevin Smith
man had I known I would have worn a
leather jacket or just something I
counted on you wearing this you were I
was this close dude I almost wore the
hoodie from the southwest incident I was
gonna play keV Smith from two years ago
right but I wore this thank God
otherwise that would have been a bit of
a buzzkill
this is actually a pretty good look for
us yeah yeah very comfy I can see why
you do it I just oh my god for those
listening at home Ralph is dressed like
a really great director
there's my Scorsese outfit this is what
I would look like then though you're
haunting me right on stage like every
time I look over I'm like oh that's what
it could be
thanks for coming out to the special
Halloween Babylon we are having a little
contest where'd you get the Jersey I had
you're your assistant smuggle it out of
your house for me [ __ ] magnet
[Music]
you
[Music]